are you ready
okay
all right so again we're learning to
parry so we're just going to start here
i'm going to be above his elbow
not below his elbow
okay
and we want to we're learning going from
the outside first
so double factor parry above his elbow
and back to my corner of my shoulder
followed by
the other parry
comes back to the corner of my shoulder
so i don't want to go outside my
shoulders
only protect me
boom here's raya
let me do the other side
okay so that's basic let's pay attention
to
uh the positioning on the outside
above my elbow
do it
above my elbow because he's above my
elbow
okay
and have your fingers
up so you have the larger surface area
don't expect to grab me
the largest surface area
boom
okay if he is below my elbow and i'm
gonna come around it's very fast
he has to be above my elbow
comes above my elbow
right
here
i can't get around that thing okay
below my elbow i get around it easy
always above the elbow on the outside
above the elbow on the outside
that's basic for those of you are here
you want to go better than that
you'll have the adhesion so i'm not
going like this
i'm well you have so you have the
beginner training spot
and then you have a more difficult on
the outside
stickiness
[Music]
i don't care
next thing you do as he puts his hand up
versus static
which is fine this kid's class
but as he puts his hand up i'm already
making contact with it like with our
sword work
oh alrighty
[Music]
all right
catch the elbow source
not here that is beginner kid stuff okay
like catch the elbow at the source
so the fruition of his arm positioning
he's already in the technique it's not a
response to his punch
i've already got it
[Music]
okay so train at one of those levels go
uh
can i have one
here we go
let's spread around get around around
okay
so we're just going to take that inward
pair
got it
don't hit the ball a million miles away
just do the form
i'm not trying to jack him up i'm just
giving him a more dynamic uh element
okay
so mid-foot weight since you're training
at your level all right you're still
kind of on your heels dude you still
have heel weight
you see
his knee should not be able to blow you
over
now we're going to work on it okay so
just the inward pair
that's going to be this one
it goes out
and to your shoulder
resist the temptation to knock the ball
all right let's start that drill go
okay
um
you can't blink
but then you're not you're not going to
be able to do technique okay
so uh this drill
i don't get my eyes open even if i have
like
i gotta keep oh eyes open
don't go like this
so all i'm gonna do now oh keep my eyes
open and i'm gonna let that ball touch
me in the face
well you can aim a little better
right here
boom keep my eyes open oh keep my eyes
open
keep my eyes open okay let's try that
drill then we'll move on go
all right
whatever way he's parrying so he's doing
that perry's pairing to his right his
head will go to the left
you see his head goes that way so you're
this is for those older your angle of
deflection
is contrary to your angle of deviation
so his angle deflection is going north
his head goes south you got it
his head does not do this stuff
especially if your name is priscilla
okay your head goes like this
that's it
he has to keep his eyes open so same
drill
no you're going to repair it this time
there
then the other side
and then the other side
okay let's go
okay
now they add in the double factor parry
so let's practice it again
boom and his head movement the same side
you can step if you want it boom okay
you go to the other side
nope
it's not whacks on myself there's again
this side
go boom okay and this side you ground
you found yourself
yeah good there you go okay here we go
are you gonna do it you probably won't
touch the ball with the second hand we
don't care we wanted to go back to the
shoulder
good come back to the shoulder and don't
trap your own arm
there you go
good no i'm not floating okay go
[Music]
all right
so i'm going to first learn the
homolateral vector so that means i'm
going to step through
and just push this hand towards his face
so start with your stepping foot in the
back
don't hand off
and he's gonna do that ferry
maybe move down all the way inside
do the other side
he has to keep his eyes open
he will hang white like that
so he looks at it
gets used to it coming to his face
okay
let's go
okay so he's going to do it
i don't want to take away my fighting
position do you see this posture i have
here that's not good
so same same way this way
that's not where the action is the
action is over here okay
likewise let's switch sides
should be able to attack
you're here
so i'm going to make you touch that
the first period comes around
hits that rib cage
not out here
very tight
okay let's go